welcome to another tutorial in this one
I'll be showing you how to reverse and
reverse or change the speed of a video
in Camtasia statistics so firstly
there's obviously open taking statistics
and I will Vegas for seven of
information so faking but is not reverse
or to speed up such they are anything
you want maybe even if a man can't you
statistics zealously fertile oh here it
is and once you have importing you're on
your project here we go to add tags and
import Mia and import the actual um
import what you want to be sped up slow
down reversed for everyone so go ahead
and I'll just take that if you're here I
have and if you file this will work with
a number of different file types all you
wanna do is drag down to the dog onto
the timeline and you're asking your
anything connections you can choose
whatever you want it will work with
whatever editing donations you want I'll
choose a 720p one and then once you've
done this we're just going to select
that red key frame select the right hand
and drag it and highlight the entire
phrase he'll be one change this VM and
we want it right click and click and say
crispy and this is where API the clip
speed comes in we can change it to two
hundred percent of the original secret
which is even yes would shorten the new
clip duration to half a time and will
play obviously twice to speak you can
also notice here we have an eight
hundred percent you want once I think
that's a little unrealistic you might
not be able to hear yourself another
thing you can do is actually set to
negative one hundred percent which would
play your video backwards so he said to
100 or every gamer speed and that's it
so if you want to set it to me ten
twenty three percent faster and all you
can do that and I will get a surface
video to succeed show you guys what
sounds like when you've done a sandwich
at 150 percent of the original clips me
here okay and you're looking up then you
could see it's only visible after the
video has introduced so it's not like
something biggest where you actually see
the preview and where you see what
you've already done in a preview window
here alright close and now that face
that I think right clicking to wherever
else whatever other anything I need to
do then simply hit produce video and
you'll go through your whole pretty six
out and the video will be produced and
that's me so um thanks for watching this
tutorial was helpful
Rayudu them who are willing for 180 and
change the video speed of your video so
thanks a lot to listen if you have a
tutorial ideas or requests for me I'll
try to send a message and I'll try the
idea for you and video hey PC
backgrounds also coming up so thanks for
watching